une salle pleine pour cette réunion
publique de jean baptiste à monique le
conseiller départemental du modem
présente sa liste sans étiquette soutenu
également par le parti présidentiel
ses soutiens politiques ce ne sont pas
des soutiens nous sommes allés chercher
ces des personnes des soutiens qui se
retrouvent dans ce que nous proposons
tant sur le fond que sur la forme et qui
ont décidé de nous apporter leur soutien
à une liste citoyenne et locales pour
élaborer son programme le collectif a
mené une enquête d'octobre à janvier
auprès des habitants 450 personnes ont
répondu et parmi les priorités
l'environnement donc là nous aurons
justement des mesures fortes je pense
notamment un objectif de zéro
artificialisation des sols que nous
inscrirons au pnud afin que nous
sanctuariserons nos espaces naturels et
puis nous voudront pousser la transition
écologique local de plus en plus
viennent ensuite la démocratie de
proximité la sécurité et le
développement économique notamment
auprès du commerce local
le commerce local le centre que c'est un
point important dans une ville comme
villepreux on attend à la fois au niveau
central mais aussi dans les quartiers
que des commerçants qui sont la vie en
fait la vie même d'une d'une cité puisse
être dynamique et on est tout à fait
prêts à nous engager pour les aider afin
il pr naturellement envisageant travail
rapproché avec la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur cette
thématique économique prochaine réunion
publique le 28 février quatre autres
listes sont déclarés dans la commune